everybody is and asking you guys what's
your biggest bad mom moment but what has
been your biggest good mom moment that
you were like totally like hey I'm
awesome I rock I have it every night
every night that we put Wyatt down we
high-five each other we're like we did
it every single day we kept her alive
we're like she's alive and we're still
in love like it's a you high-five would
you still like each other and used to
like your kid at the end of the night
because I'm them throw the devil there
as a bonding thing isn't it yes what
would you say is the biggest thing that
you and I should have bonded over I mean
having a kid with a baby I mean we're
with her in moments with with Wyatt when
when it's health like when it's the
worst possible we was like ooh pop the
back and it's like vomit all over and
she was maybe like six weeks old maybe
and it was like the second wakeup of the
night with like the explosive you know
of all any kind of just laughs and we
started looked at each other to start
laughing and it was like the greatest
sense of relief instead of like being
frustrated we were like oh my god then
he was like this remember this moment
because soon you're gonna blink and
she's gonna be going to school and I'm
so grateful that we laughed and
remembered the absurdity of this one
night